going on I'm not from this world I need
your help with my quest to stop the
uprising it's time to celebrate Asian
American and Pacific Islander heritage
month and here are five titles that will
help you do just that
every may we love to recognize the
contributions and influence of aapi
Americans to the history and culture of
the United States and of course that
means tons of great movies and shows and
while you may already have your go-to
titles for such an occasion here are
five more like those that are worth
checking out starting with our brand new
pick american-born Chinese this comedy
series is based on the 2006 graphic
novel of the same name and stars the
incomparable Michelle yo she plays the
mother of a struggling boy who meets a
new exchange student and becomes
involved in a battle of Chinese
mythological Gods classic scenario with
directors like Lucy Liu and Dustin
Daniel behind the camera this
Disney Plus show is a fresh hit with
critics a little over four hours is all
you'll need to get through this one
eventually which will leave you plenty
of time to track down and read the
graphic novel for it too
face of Your World hangs in the balance
I don't really see how I fit into this
whole thing or my guide
let me talk about something a little bit
cooler than guide servant yeah I know
you're right guys better our certified
fresh pick this week is the Apple TV
plus series Pachinko based on a New York
Times bestseller this show follows a
Korean immigrant family across four
generations as they leave their Homeland
to chase their dreams the certified
fresh fur season has been a hit with
pretty much everyone with the critics
calling Pachinko a sweeping epic that
captures the Arc of history as well as
the enduring bonds of family arcs of
history and bonds of family now that is
impressive the show has already picked
up bafta and Emmy Noms and it also won
the Critics Choice Award for best
foreign language series that helped pave
the way for a second season which is on
the way so for now you can watch the
first one in just over eight hours so
please enjoy it
[Music]
heading back to the early 90s is always
a good idea and that's what we're doing
for our throwback pick the Joy Luck Club
this movie was directed by Wayne Wang a
pioneer of Asian American Cinema and
it's based on the 1989 novel of the same
name by Amy Tan who also co-wrote the
screenplay the certified fresh film
explores the relationships between
chinese-american women and their
immigrant mothers and it does that well
according to critics who credit the
joyloc club for unearthing Universal
truths as it traces a generational
divide through this specific lens it
clocks in at about 2 hours and 20
minutes which is long by early 90s
standards but it is part of the national
film registry now so you better
recognize
my mother
mother not to know
her but you're too late too late for her
but not too late for you
are under the radar pick this week is
the series young Rock and if that sounds
like it could be the name of a show
about Dwayne The Rock Johnson's life
then you are totally right this NBC
comedy actually shows three periods of
Johnson's Life as a 10 year old in
Hawaii a high schooler in Pennsylvania
and a college football player in Miami
shout out to the you young Rock has been
rolling for three seasons anchored by a
certified first that critics call quote
an endearing peek behind the curtain of
both Johnson's childhood and the wild
world of wrestling come for the 13 and a
half hour watch time for all three
seasons and stay for the appearances of
Johnson as a presidential candidate in
2032 or save for Randall Park as a talk
show hosting future version of himself
remember it is a rare opportunity to
compete on the stage that big give it
everything you got it all became clear
not to express my true self Dewey looks
so cute when he's acting tough and
finally our editors pick is the Netflix
series never have I ever this
coming-of-age comedy was co-created by
Mindy Kaling and it's Loosely based on
her childhood following a modern Day
first generation Indian American teenage
girl it has three super certified fresh
Seasons ooh did I just make up a thing
super certified anyway critics love its
fresh Shake on the coming of age comedy
and call it quote hilariously honest and
sweetly smart a fourth and final season
will Premiere in June but until then
you'll need 15 hours to watch the Super
certified fresh first three seasons
we're rebranding I have chosen
attainable yet status enhancing people
for each of us today hey Jonah you smell
great today it's Forever by Mariah Carey
oh well my friends that does it for this
list and don't forget that you can find
many more great movies and shows to help
you celebrate Asian American and Pacific
Islander heritage month at
rottentomatoes.com be sure to let us
know what you are currently streaming in
the comments and check back here for
more recommendations based on the titles
that you love on Rotten Tomatoes more
like this I'm Nas Perez and I'll see you
later friends
[Music]
thank you